trying on
oh it's our time to strike two of them
the demand and expectations for your
sequel is at an all-time high and you've
had to deal with the loss of like you're
Leading Men the pandemic and of course
the pressure of crafting a stronger even
better sequel what was your greatest
challenge in making this movie and how
did you overcome it I would say the
greatest challenge in in making a movie
was was probably just stamina you know
and perseverance it was a process that
was that took longer than anybody
expected it to take due to challenges
that no one could predict nobody because
she coming and that we didn't really
have any control over and so I think
just just being able to stick with it uh
and face of these challenges and delays
and complications and being able to
still you know be creative and and uh
and Lead all of the incredible artists
that were you know lending us their
talents
um I think that was that was the most
challenging part but I will say it's
also been the most rewarding part you
know I think that we we've made a I
think we've made that something that's
really exciting you know we were making
another 10 circumstances the movie is
still very fun you know it has a lot of
humor in it a lot of rewatch value
um and also it's something that feels
that feels true to us that that's not
easy to do it's not it's not uh it's not
often that that that happens um so I
think that uh I think that the
challenges were very much working okay
so you recently shared the original plot
of the sequel and how it was supposed to
be like a deep dive into t'challa psyche
um well enough forever sees a different
story now but what are some things that
you kept consistent in both of these
stories that's a great question I think
things that we kept consistent in both
stories were you know are the themes of
perseverance
um I would say uh the theme of
confronting grief the motif of water uh
you know uh Neymar and Telecom where
we're present in that version of the
story
um and I think that uh that those things
were those things were kept but but some
of the some of the pivots that we made
you know the film became
um very quickly the film became a movie
that dealt with motherhood and it dealt
with you know how you move forward After
experiencing
um After experiencing in loss you know
on multi-levels uh or all that uh all
that t'challa occupied for the
characters you know you know has has
been has been lost and the characters
are coming off of uh the events of uh
infinity war and end game
um where where people have missed you
know time five years away and and have
come back to find what kind of be in a
different place the idea of growth and
maturity I think um is explored in this
film in a way that that it was explored
a little bit in the other draft and I'm
I'm honestly
you know so excited about this film and
sharing sharing this feeling I think
that uh you know to compare it to
compare it to that to that to that drive
is almost like a disservice to it you
know you know I'm looking forward to to
people seeing it I'm really excited to
catch it uh and I love that you changed
no More's background in this movie I
think it's about time we see you know
Hispanic and Indigenous communities on
screen especially in a superhero film
how did that idea come about and how did
you have that discussion with Kevin
feige the idea came about in a pretty
natural way to to have
um uh to adapt you know what was
Atlantis in the in the comic books to to
be in talocon in the MCU
um in in Beijing their their culture
um off of the the Mayan culture or the
classic and post classic period uh that
that that idea was a was a product of a
lot of different things that that that
we were feeling creatively
um but the biggest one was making the
first black panther you know we kind of
built a a language of filmmaking for
ourselves uh I think an expectation from
the audience that we would that we would
take cultural research and
representation serious that we would do
the work to make sure that we weren't
just putting things in there for no
reason and and and that we were picking
and pulling things from from real
cultures and presenting them in a way
that I was respectful and so we have to
do that same thing and you know to make
a follow-up uh to that to that to that
film in this black panther series uh you
know I thought we had to open the world
up you know after the world had to get
bigger the scope had to get bigger our
shoulders were big enough to carry more
on on this one and it made sense to
involve a culture that wasn't on the
continent you know um and and you know I
was born in California
you know uh and and you know very
familiar with the indigenous cultures
here in in um North America how a great
influence over my life you know just as
a person
um so I was excited about about the
opportunity to include uh some of those
smallest cultures some of those
indigenous North American Mesoamerican
cultures in the in in the film and look
at you know look at those cultures in
the Black Panther and the Black Panther
lens you know like when we're using them
for inspiration and and hopefully we can
uh Inspire audiences to to want to you
know go back and look at look at more
look at more uh uh history and and ask
more questions and and
um develop their own fiction their own
movies you know what I mean that could
be inspired by by some of the work that
we do here uh so I was really excited in
terms of a conversation with Kevin you
know look it wasn't like a big uh it
wasn't a big deal you know like he he
was he was he actually encouraged it
because he he did want us to to make
sure that our version of an underwater
uh Society is different enough to be
able to coexist in the in in the film
world right now and there have been a
lot of representations and and we we
felt like the more different that we can
make it you know the more our respect
the other you know the other
presentations you know what I mean you
got you got Aquaman which is a great
film you got
you know these other these other these
other movies that are based on uh uh you
know Plato's Atlantis for lack of a
better time or Greco-Roman if you study
you know kind of hit historical text and
cultures you'll see that there are a lot
of cultures all over the world that have
this Legend of of hidden Society
continents that sunk and went into the
water into the ocean I was kind of
amazed when I started to look into that
I didn't realize okay this this group
this culture doesn't con you know
doesn't claim full ownership over this
as an idea you know we can look at we
can look at doing another way and once
we once we did that we settled on um on
the Mayan civilization and it worked out
really well for us
down
you know what time
show them
Who We Are
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]